I get a little serious here talk about
something that was on the minds of a lot
of serious minded Americans Iran in the
news this week today Iran cut their oil
exports to Europe well at the same time
claiming they've taken another step
toward nuclear capability now this is
causing a lot of tension in the Middle
East and around the world
now Andy thinks all this could lead the
United States into a war I happen to
disagree so as you can imagine it's a
great opportunity for another Konan Andy
whipped cam debate you ready Andy yes I
am toning here we go
it rands latest moves amount to nothing
more than saber rattling the last thing
they want is a war with the United
States you've got it wrong Conan the
world community has backed I ran into a
corner and they're bound to lash out
that's what Iran wants us to think
but like the Cuban Missile Crisis when
pushes the brink they're sure to fold
that's dangerous and wishful thinking
Conan no it's not yes it is no it's not
Conan for the last time yes it is I have
a big black bushy mustache why got big
got proof oh yeah well I've arranged a
special cameo by a big television star
I'm Jack McBrayer making a pointless
celebrity cameo nice to see you jack
nice to see you too you know Jack you're
not getting paid for this I'm not not a
penny
[Laughter]
shame on you mr. O'Brian
[Applause]
[Music]
we got a great show tonight ladies and
gentlemen hosts CMT's my big redneck
vacation actor comedian our friend Tom
Arnold on the river
you should wear this teeth every night
that looks fantastic
it's a little hard to talk that's all
right
[Laughter]